The Beatles was the only band where
every single guy in the band was a star
their own songs and wrote and that was
the model that we did when you uh Paul
was here the other day and he talked
about how I I can't remember what the
guy's name is but he brought you over
and you met Paul in in his Stephen
Carnell who was my uh
Junior High School Chomp you know we
hung out and we actually wrote some
early songs together that kiss
eventually recorded but you you're in
the apartment and you said to Paul play
something for me he played something I
was I was uh
I had never met anybody else that wrote
their own songs so in my deluded way
I've always been delusional
uh which works for me I know I'm not the
best looking guy in the world but I
don't care I will go home with your
girlfriend there's no question about
that guys and and her mom too and her
mom and then he'll go take them shopping
in New York
and so when I first met Paul
uh Steve introduced me to him and said
you know he said this guy's Paul then
his name was Stan the ice right
uh he writes songs too and I sort of in
my mind I went oh really let's let's see
what you got and of course I came off
like an [ __ ] and to him I was I
didn't mean it that way but he hated me
right off the bat and he played me if
you had a guitar here I could show you
exactly what he did a song we have a
guitar in the place Sunday driver and I
went wow that's a well-written song
let me be your Sunday driver let me be
your Monday man wow I'll do whatever
just as fast as I can
wow yeah that's a that's really good he
says okay now you play what you got so I
played one of my early songs but the
early songs I wrote were just horrible
my uncle is a raft and he always keeps
me floating
[Laughter]
he treats me tenderly it doesn't matter
who you are
my uncle is around he said that's awful
we do have a guitar hanging on the wall
when you come in yeah you know we're at
the front door hanging on the wall the
eagle I think it's not tune well I don't
know oh I can tune fast he could tune in
Fast and so uh a lot of people don't
realize this but whether it's Hendricks
or really the top
most popular musicians I don't mean EDM
Artists who don't play
or
don't knock EDM you have a daughter that
does EDM but she plays instruments and
writes songs okay she's a legitimate
okay artist I don't want you to knock
what the kids are doing she's huge what
that's okay because I plug into
something no you don't need to oh you
don't need to nah whose is it Chili
Peppers Chili Peppers
I'll see you good enough yeah
so
[Applause]
so he comes up and goes
[Music]
there you go let there be your Sunday
travel let me be your Monday man I'm
going oh that's pretty good I'll take
you anywhere I've got just as fast as I
can
I go that's a really good song that's
the first thing you remember that I'm
kidding we later recorded it and uh
called it uh
let me know and then you let me know
that's that's something you wanted to
record it with you though even though
you said that he you came off Eric or he
didn't like you well eventually we
decided that despite my
personality shortcomings that we needed
to be in the same band
do you have is there between you and
Paul because you're both very talented
but also very vibrant personalities is
that like I would imagine because you
write songs and he writes songs is there
uh um a clash sometimes
in the way you think of it
but
the core
personality trait that we both share is
responsible
you work hard the word responsible that
we're both responsible that that thing
we should show up on time you do the
work whatever needs to be done is that
why you voted some of the other members
out because you were doing more work
than Optical that's another big word
like gymnasium what do you mean you got
well it's tough to drive a car with flat
tires
so friends or no friends we didn't put a
band together to have friends and hang
out you wanted to put a band together so
you could make it and if people use
drugs and alcohol and it impairs your
performance just like on a soccer field
if somebody you pass the ball to
somebody and they can't get the goal
because they're high get rid of their
sorry ass both you and Paul have lived a
very clean life as far as I've never
been high or drunk in my life never
smoked cigarettes that's so not the
epitome of what people think rock and
roll is that and to this day when I meet
people you know they're often high and
are blabbering
[Music]